[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So today
is a review session.
But let me start by looking
at the class schedule.
And today is the review session.
So there's no
readings for today.
Note the lectures are
numbered seven, eight,
so today doesn't count somehow.
But it does show up
on the class schedule.
It does not show up as a
numbered lecture on the reading
list.
I find these, going over
randomly selected questions
on the study guide,
to be very helpful.
Taking a bit of time to go over,
as we usually do, in this case
after the end of lecture seven,
is definitely worthwhile.
So this question was
already asked of me.
So granted, it's kind of a hard
question to write and maybe
not so obvious how to answer.
Go back to the medieval
village economy
and think about how
you would model it
in general equilibrium terms.
Volunteer.
How do we model the
medieval village economy
in general equilibrium terms?
And he's ready to answer this
but we already talked about it.
Yes, who's speaking?
STUDENT: I was going
to say that it includes
the possible consumption set,
and the production vectors that
are possible, and the
endowment for that economy.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
And the preferences.
STUDENT: Yeah, and that.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, so that's good.
So then what aspects
of the medieval economy
do you remember
from figures and so
on that look like
one of those things?
What about production?
Well, either this question
is too hard or too easy.
I'm not sure which.
So one answer I didn't
give, the key just now,
is we actually thought
about the medieval village
when we did the dynamics
of storage, and starvation,
and so on.
And we wrote down a
production technology
mapping inputs and outputs.
So we were doing production,
and we took a stand on utility.
And so that was an example of
a medieval village economy,
except there was only
one person in it.
But--
If you go back to
those pictures,
we have a map with
a given person
having its plots spread out all
over the map of the village.
So do you think they have the
same production technologies
or different production
technologies?
Anybody can answer.
This is a little
discussion period.
Well, if it were the same
production technology,
then why on Earth would they
be spreading their land out
over the village
into different spots?
So it seems likely they're
different production
technologies.
In what way do you think
they might be different?
I'm going to call on someone.
This isn't working.
Ewan, can you try
to answer that--
in what reasonable
way do you think
the production
technology is different
across different plots?
STUDENT: Maybe the
multiplier that
determines the state of
the world is independent,
or there are fewer correlations
the further out you go.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, good.
OK.
So what in the
storage economy was
that epsilon might have
different realizations
for different plots,
and then we get
into all that stuff about
correlations, and covariances,
and so on.
Yeah.
So as I was saying, the
key at the beginning, this
is kind of a difficult question.
That's why she asked me at
right when we logged on at 2:30.
It's difficult-- why?
Because you're so
used to seeing me
show you slides of things,
like here's the model,
and then you're,
like, OK, I guess
I better learn this model.
And I just put you in the
different position of asking
you to choose the model.
That is a very interesting
skill and it is not something
you get to practice very often.
That's why I think this
question is hard in the sense
that you're not
used to doing that.
But that's the way economists
have to think about things.
We make decisions.
It's not like God is giving
us preferences, endowments,
and technology.
We're kind of making it up,
hopefully for good reason.
All right, so that's why I
earmarked that question today.
For the set of feasible
allocations in an Edgeworth box
economy, which allocations are
Pareto optimal and which not?
And if we had the whiteboard,
I would ask you to draw it,
but I'm not going to
be that ambitious.
So can someone just
tell me in words?
How about Paolo.
Can you take a stab at this.
STUDENT: Yeah, sure.
So the set of all Pareto optimal
allocations inside of the box
are the set of points for
which the indifference
curves for person one and person
two are tangent to each other
because then you can optimize.
There's no lens-shaped
region for you
to do something that's better.
And everything else is just
like a non-Pareto optimal
allocation.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK, that's
great, excellent answer.
And maybe if we get that
far in our review session,
all the way back here
to lecture seven,
we can take a look at
some of those pictures.
Here's another one.
What is the relationship
between maximized linear welfare
functions and Pareto optimality?
STUDENT: So whenever we maximize
a linear welfare function,
the resulting
allocation is guaranteed
to be Pareto optimal.
And I think conversely, any
Pareto-optimal allocation
optimizes some linear
social welfare function.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Perfect answer.
Now I'm a happy camper.
Thank you.
You guys do really well on
these more precisely worded
questions.
That's a very good answer.
Thank you so much.
And let's see-- that's
probably enough of that.
So I'm going to scroll
through these lectures
with two goals in mind.
One, as I go through the slides,
sometimes pretty quickly,
please let me know if
you have a question.
Even if you didn't
plan to ask it,
you might think of something.
It might come back to you when
you're looking at the material.
And secondly, I will try to
summarize a bit in key spots
and draw some connections of
one lecture to another one.
So that's the plan.
The substance of
this first lecture
had to do with economics as
a science of experiments.
And I covered these
four different authors.
Let me just not dwell on it.
The point was economics
as an experiment,
in the sense of physics and
combining various disciplines
to do this.
And Koopmans is
making this point
that it's much more
than just measurement.
And constantly in the
course, I am showing you
measurements of things, facts,
and statistics, and so on.
But like Koopmans,
that's not enough.
We want to have a good sense
of the context of the problem
or economy, but we want to
go on and understand behavior
and then make predictions.
I guess the best
illustration of our
doing this so far might be
the medieval storage problem,
where we wrote that we took
the medieval village we were
discussing earlier, talked
about preferences, endowments,
and technology.
We did some calibration
to put in serious numbers
representing risk, and
returns, and so on.
And then we
simulated the economy
and pretty much got
it to match the data.
So that was, I guess, the
most full-blown application
we've done so far in this
tradition of Koopmans,
although Koopmans goes on to
talk about what he thinks is
the real goal, which is policy.
And we did not do any
policy simulations in that.
We didn't change
something and ask
if we could remedy the
problem, for example.
But we will be doing much more
of that as the class goes on.
Matzkin has this language
about exogenous and endogenous
variables.
And we've, again in that
medieval village economy,
I think I was using
that terminology--
things that are taken
as given versus things
we want to explain.
Angrist was talking about
randomized controlled trials
and comparing them to
quasi-natural experiments.
This first example was
paying bicycle messengers
a higher wage.
And a couple of
comments on that--
when we get to utility functions
and utility maximization
subject to budgets, we
actually had a picture
of someone choosing how
much labor to supply
as a function of the wage.
So this should not
be abstract anymore.
And we actually
did look at an RCT
in China that had
to do with changing
the price of a staple commodity,
which was featured in problem
set one.
So what am I doing?
What on Earth am
I doing right now?
I'm not trying to give
this lecture again.
I'm trying to tell you that
we're delivering on it.
I mentioned these concepts
in the very first lecture,
was probably quite abstract.
But now we're already
beginning to be
able to fill in with the
material that came afterwards.
Yeah, I think this is
more issues of modeling.
Lucas artificial
economies-- I'll
go back to that
dynamic lecture where
I said they could be
feeding grain to the animals
or turning it into beer.
And I said we would ignore that.
That represented a
choice so that we
could focus on what
arguably were the two
most important storage devices.
So we constructed an
artificial economy
to compare to the real data.
And Lucas mentioned computation.
And you can see
through these lectures
that I have not shied
away from telling you
how to determine solutions.
We did this with
Lagrangian stuff,
with a set of
first-order conditions
you could use to help predict
and understand the solution.
And then we went
to linear programs.
We went to dynamic programs.
And we'll do more
as we go along,
depending on what we need to
do, depending on the lecture.
And then this list
of economies--
we had a great discussion
about this on the last slide
of the dynamic problem.
We shifted gears, and went
to a modern US economy
with some credit instruments.
And I'll come back to that.
But this first economy, the
medieval village economy,
you've obviously seen depicted
in about three different
lectures so far.
The Thai village
economy has entered
into the discussion,
economies where they didn't
try to diversify
ex ante, and they
need to potentially
to share risk ex post.
And we haven't done
much with trade yet,
although we haven't touched
these other two yet.
The Lucas trees we did
in that dynamic lecture
because we talked about yield
to seed ratios, how much harvest
they're getting per unit
of land planted in seed.
And then I turned again,
at the end of that lecture,
to a dynamic problem in a
different economy, where
they had an asset that was
like a borrowing or lending
contract with its own return.
So we went from farming
to financial assets.
So hopefully, that's an example.
This we just did--
what's an economy?
Preferences, endowments,
and technology.
We've now got examples of it and
we developed notation for it.
And throughout, I keep
trying to emphasize
this can be applied to economies
with dynamics with geography
and with uncertainty.
Hopefully, you're getting
bored with my comments,
in the sense of yeah,
yeah, yeah, we know.
I hope you do know,
but my experience
has been these things
bear repeating.
What are we going to do?
We did that in the first
lecture, then we did it .
And now we're coming
back to what did we do.
So it is a review, after all.
Lecture two was about
consumer choice.
And we reviewed what's
an economy-- preference,
endowments, and technology--
as if to say now we're going
to focus only on preferences.
Motivationally, I'm very nervous
about this part of the course
and also the same
slide for production,
because then we kind of forget
the whole general economy
thing, which is the prize
that we want to get to.
But we can't get
to the big picture
with all the
ingredients combined
until we understand the pieces.
So this piece was
about the consumer.
And we applied it, though we
did try to not just make things
to memorize or theory.
We tried to apply it at
the end of this lecture
and in the following two--
maximization of utility
subject to budgets.
So we described the consumption
set, various special versions
that have time and geography.
And we've talked about this.
This is, again, one of the
great, little questions
we had at the beginning
of the following class.
And we talked about
consumer preferences,
rank-ordering goods,
defined rational choice
as preferences which are
complete, transitive,
and continuous.
And then we talked
about a utility function
representing preferences.
A couple of things
came up here--
it was ordinal and not cardinal,
and we talked about that.
But we will and did need
cardinal representations
when we got to uncertainty
and dynamic decision problems.
Second thing is this
was a chat on Piazza.
This slide goes from having
a continuous utility.
Any preference that
can be represented
by a continuous
utility function is
rational in the sense
of the definition
of the previous slide.
And then someone initiated
the obvious question,
does it also go the other way--
that any rational preference
function can be represented
as a continuous utility?
And the answer was,
yes, although there
was a good discussion about
distinguishing continuity
on the one hand from the
other two ingredients--
completeness and transitivity.
So that was a great
discussion on Piazza.
Local nonsatiation--
this is kind
of a definition of being
close by and getting better.
I talked about no bliss points.
I think in words, we talked
about utility functions
with bliss points, but we
never put any pictures in.
You might be thinking,
could I draw a picture
with a bliss point, and
what would it look like?
More is preferred to less.
Largely I'm scrolling through
this, and hopefully quickly,
just to make sure if you
have questions or not.
Indifference curves, the whole
family of indifference curves.
Indifferent serves can't
cross because then they
wouldn't be transitive.
Margin rates of substitution
were defined, typically
diminishing, although
not necessarily.
And various displays of into
families of indifference
for different utility
functions, running all the way
from perfect substitutes
to perfect complements.
This one over here, the
right-angled indifference
curves, represent
Leontiefian preferences
where there's no
substitutability.
We're about to get to maximizing
utility subject to budgets.
You might play
around a little bit
and see what happens with
these particular preferences
when you do that.
What happens when
you change prices?
That would be an
interesting experiment
to conduct because you'll get
really sharp predictions that
are distinct from what
you would get in this more
typical smooth case.
And I'm anticipating reviewing
the production lecture
in two lectures away.
So now, you're able to go
back and forth between what
do indifference curves
look like and consumption
versus isoquants or isoproduct
lines in production.
This one, the Leontief thing,
we didn't talk about it much
in consumer theory but we did
talk about it in production,
and you probably didn't
make the connection.
But I'll try to remember to
point out where we actually
used it in production.
These are examples of utility
functions and definitions
of convexity and
quasi-concavity.
There are a lot of
different concepts here.
They were all illustrated
as holding or not
holding, depending on how
we draw these pictures.
Convexity turns out
to be important,
especially when we're
drawing pictures
of tangencies and optimization.
Things can really
go kind of crazy
when you don't have convexity.
Here, it's convexity of the
weak upper contour set of it,
weakly preferred bundles.
A little more technical
derivation of the marginal rate
of substitution, and something
about homothetic preferences,
where the slope of the
indifference curves
are determined entirely by
the ratio of the two goods.
We kept coming back to this
picture in different ways.
In the next lecture
in fact, there's
something about angles
curves, and necessities,
and Giffen goods, and so on.
Suffice it to say
that if you're moving
outwards along this ray--
because maybe your income
is increased, holding prices
constant-- the goods x1 and x2
are increasing proportionally
with the distance
along this ray.
And likewise, since
prices are fixed,
expenditure is also moving
proportionally along this ray.
The preferences
were not homothetic.
Then this would not be
a line from the origin.
It would start to bend.
And that actually
was what was going
on when we talked about income
effects and substitution
effects.
That's coming up in
the next lecture.
We haven't used this
utility function very much,
although it will appear soon.
And we did talk about
utility functions
which are completely linear.
So finally, we get to the
utility maximization problem--
max utility is
subject to a budget--
and defined homogeneity in
this consumer theory context,
and started to generate these
pictures of income budget
lines, and the set of
all possible purchases
in and under the budget line,
and the utility-maximizing
positions.
Although again, this is kind
of the classic smooth diagram
that sometimes is the
only diagram you see.
I'm bending over
backwards to show you
different pictures like this
one, where the maximum is not
interior.
You do want to keep an eye out
about whether they would be
happy with this quantity of y,
or whether they would actually
like to go negative
and just cannot do it
because of the consumption set.
And we formalize
that as an example
of the use of the
Lagrangian, where
you write out this expression
with all the constraints.
And this is the generalized
routine for optimization,
and actually applying
it to the case
where we have these
non-negativity constraints
on the two goods.
This is the most general way
to deal with the problem.
It doesn't mean all these
constraints to are binding.
They may be binding
and may be not.
Typically with non-satiation, a
household with this constraint
will want to spend
all its income,
so that's usually
binding, although you
could try to draw a
picture where it's not.
Back, by the way,
to the bliss point,
but I've never shown you that.
And just because it says
"greater than or equal to,"
in other words,
non-negative, doesn't
mean they would want
it to go negative.
That depends on what
this picture looks like.
And then we did the
example utility functions.
This is Cobb-Douglas.
And you do the algebra,
and you get this result
that pX times X is
total expenditures on X.
And it's a constant,
alpha times income.
So this is an example of
budget shares being constant.
As income vary, X
and Y will vary.
The amount spent
will vary, but it's
going to vary in a linear way.
It's one-to-one with income.
And that Cobb-Douglas,
this guy here,
that's homothetic preferences.
I don't think I said that
when I was lecturing on this.
Maybe I did.
So in this case, you can
almost see it in the algebra--
the marginal rate of
substitution, which is here,
depends only on the ratio of
Y to X because this alpha is
a constant.
So this is a homothetic
utility function.
And finally, we got
to labor supply,
which is like an
application, since I
was worried that you'll
lose the context of what
we're trying to do.
So we had this picture, this
beautiful picture, of someone
starting with leisure.
This was the first time I think
we talked about an endowment.
So they're endowed with 24
hours a day or less sleep time.
I don't know if you
sleep eight hours,
but now we're down to 16.
And they can take that time
and enjoy it in leisure
or run it to 0 and work.
This diagram is in the space
of goods that consumers want.
They're going to
end up consuming
positive amounts of
leisure, positive amounts
of consumption, like
x1, x2, with both
of them being positive.
The slope of the budget
line represents the wage.
You might play
around a bit and ask
if you could draw the picture
where the choice is not
over leisure but
labor, in which case
you'd be moving
to the left here.
And then you'd have to
draw the budget line--
it's going to look similar--
and then draw preferences.
I'll show you what
I have in mind
when we get back to that
Robinson Crusoe economy.
Now let's go to lecture three.
I'm going to spend a little
bit less time on this
in terms of going through
each and every slide,
but try to focus more on
some of the key aspects.
So we had this demand system.
This would represent
data, but we're
going to assume right
away it's coming
from utility maximization.
So you can think about
this as restrictions
on data implied by
utility maximization.
This is in the spirit
of Frisch and RCTs
and various other things.
So we're increasing income.
What would happen?
This is the linear
expansion path.
But it doesn't have
to look like that.
It could look like this.
So this actually
has a negative slope
as you increase income because
the amount purchased of goods
is going down.
It could be entirely
vertical, actually.
I think you could imagine
how to draw it that way.
That utility function
I said we didn't
do much, which was transferable
utility, x1 plus log
x2, that would give you a
vertical line like this,
or horizontal.
I don't remember
which good was which,
but now the quantities
are going down or up
and the prices are constant.
Because all we're
doing is moving income.
Hence, the
expenditure shares are
moving in this diagram,
not just the quantities,
because of the nature
of the experiment.
So we defined inferior goods and
normal goods, and got to Engel.
Engel's law being,
in particular,
proportion of total
expenditure on food
goes down as income goes up.
So someone asks me--
I think it was in the Piazza
chat or was it in class--
no, it was in class.
One of you asked
me, are we talking
about quantities or
shares of expenses?
So it's kind of related.
In order for Engel's
things to be true,
some good must be, by
definition, a necessity.
But necessities were
defined by this diagram
where we just changed income
and didn't change prices.
Just trying to tie these
loose ends together.
Then we showed you what's
going on in the US.
One of you made a great
comment about this diagram,
it's kind of being tautological.
And my answer was
yes, but it's also
quantifying the differences.
And here we did the income
and substitution effects
from price changes, in
particular emphasizing
the income effect of price
changes for increases
and decreases in prices, and
plotted out the demand curves.
Some people just start with
demand curves, like this.
So where did it come from?
In particular with
aggregate demand,
is it down-sloping like this?
What's going to
happen in the economy
as a function of the virus has
to do with these elasticities
and so on.
But I prefer not to start
with this as a primitive.
I prefer to derive it and
put restrictions on it
from these underlying
first principles.
Then we defined
Giffen's paradox--
that in the famine, the Irish--
which destroyed the potatoes,
they were eating more potatoes.
We decided that couldn't
literally be factually true,
and that Giffen's thing, I
thought, had never been tested.
And then I discovered
Jensen and Miller,
and they shared their data.
And of course, the paper
was published and so on.
So this was an important part
of the course for two reasons.
It's meant to bring the
concepts of Giffen goods,
and hence the distinction
between income and substitution
effects, to life in real data.
It was also, as I said earlier,
an example of an actual RCT
in practice.
So it's not just as if we
were running an experiment.
They ran the experiment.
They actually did it.
They had households
that were treated,
households that were
control, looked at behavior,
and they did find Giffen goods.
So it's an important part
to bring the theory to life.
The second thing is it was a
big part of problem set one.
And that came with the
experience of reading
a professional paper,
having the data there ready
for you to manipulate,
run some code
to replicate what these
guys did, and to extend it.
And many of you answered
those questions.
Some of you did not or
didn't answer all of it.
At a minimum for now,
you should understand
what it was that these guys
did, and why they did it,
and what they found, quite apart
from answering that problem.
So uncompensated and
compensated demand,
also known as Hicksian
versus Marshallian demand.
This eliminates income effects.
So you move along indifference
curves when you change prices,
so it's all driven
by assumptions
about the marginal
rate of substitution.
We tended to draw these
smooth indifference curves
with declining marginal rates
of substitution, which is
the right way to get started.
But this concept should
work as well when you have
linear indifference curves.
So that links back to that other
diagram that I was mentioning,
the one with the almost-linear
indifference curve
and the price.
But in this case, we'd be
doing that and also changing
the price ratio.
So we have compensated
and uncompensated demand,
leading to Slutsky's equation.
And I don't know if
I helped or hurt,
but I actually jumped ahead
to lecture 18 or something,
and showed you eventually
how we're going to use that.
But I also told you
to ignore that detour
if it was confusing.
But this whole lecture is
about making predictions
as prices change
or income change.
And this Slutsky
equation turns out
to be something you
can measure in data.
Even though we never see
the compensated demand,
the compensated
demand has properties
because the expenditure
function is concave.
So we can actually put
some sign restrictions
on the Marshallian
demand in this way.
It's all a bit surprising,
but more on that later.
Anyway, it's about
making predictions.
And then we did duality,
which I was just
alluding to, minimizing
expenditures subject to--
here's the picture.
So this was the
first time we talked
about maximizing utilities
subject to budgets, hand
in hand with minimizing
expenditures to achieve
a certain level of utility.
So we defined a dual
problem relative
to the primary problem, and got
some useful characteristics out
of the dual.
Although in fact, if
it's a very teeny,
weeny change, and it's all
local, nothing happens.
They're equivalent.
At least, they're equivalent
with these other underlying
assumptions--
nice, smooth indifference
curves, no bliss points,
et cetera.
You could experiment with
putting in local satiation.
And then you will
discover that these things
don't have to be the same.
Maximizing utility
subject to a budget
and minimizing
expenditure to achieve
a certain level of
utility will not
be the same when you
violate the assumption
of local non-satiation.
Anyway, we developed
all this in the math,
in the end of this
lecture, and then
ended just the way we did the
previous one, with, hopefully,
another attempt to bring
this stuff to life, which
is to give the household
money incomes denoted
by a first date or
second date, and then
talk about price changes.
So it is about the distinction
between income and substitution
effects.
But here, unlike income as
exogenous and moving around,
you have money incomes
in the two dates.
All we're doing is
changing prices.
We're changing the price
of the good at date two
relative to the price
of the good at date one.
So there were two
different pictures here
depending on whether initially,
the household, as here,
is a lender, eating less
than its initial endowment.
We talked about
an income effect.
You can see that as we move
from the solid blue line
to the pale blue line, in
this upper quadrant at least,
the new budget line lies
further toward the northeast
than the original one.
And since they started
here, locally the effect
of the interest change is
to give them more income.
But they don't have
to end up with higher
consumption of the second good.
They could have ended up
with lower consumption.
It's really hard
to focus in there.
I have to put it right
there or something.
So it would be a little bit
lower than it was initially,
and that's despite the
increase in income.
So that's the case
where the substitution
effect is getting washed out.
So again, here, they
start out as a borrower,
and now when the
interest rate goes up,
they clearly have less income,
which intuitively makes sense
because they were
already borrowing.
And an increase in
the interest rate
can only increase the amount
of debt if they stay put.
But they would not stay put.
Then the two effects have to
do with income and substitution
effects.
They have the same sign
for consumption today,
but opposing signs for
consumption tomorrow.
So I think I went
back the next class
and made the comment that this
is an important stepping stone
toward modeling entire
economies because we're giving
the household an endowment.
In the labor example,
we gave the household
an endowment of time.
Here, we're giving the household
an endowment of money income
in each of two periods.
So the endowments are
part of an economy.
Preferences are clearly
being described here.
Production was suppressed
because it's just
a consumer problem.
So that was lecture three.
Next up is lecture four.
So I may speed up a little bit.
That said, there's a ton
of stuff in lecture four,
and we did not get through it
deliberately the first time.
There's three or four
slides at the end
that we moved to
the next lecture.
Because by topic,
it's about production,
but there are just too
many important concepts.
Repeat-- preferences,
endowment, technology-- now
zero in on technology.
That question that
we were discussing
about describe medieval
villages as an economy also
made reference to Northern
Thai villages as an economy.
Here's the picture.
So what's the technology here?
Land, labor, and capital
are used as inputs
to produce this crop.
So this, in many respects,
should not have been hard.
But then again,
I'm not asking you
to memorize all these
beautiful pictures,
just saying that because
I took this picture.
Sorry.
So production-- we have
inputs and negative, outputs,
which are positive, and vectors,
and indexed by particular goods
and by firms, potentially.
We have this production
possibility set,
where inputs being negative,
like labor over here,
and outputs being positive.
This one displays a region
of increasing and decreasing
returns to scale, to
be defined momentarily.
We went through these properties
of production functions.
And there was a good
discussion coming up, namely
decreasing constant and
increasing returns to scale.
This was the picture of
decreasing returns to scale.
This is a picture of
increasing returns.
This is a "typo" because
according to the definition,
you should take a point
in the production set
and multiply it by a
lambda greater than 1,
which I mentioned in class.
We have not tried to
correct the picture.
That's because
what this displays
is a violation of
decreasing returns
relative to them being
satisfied on the left.
They're not satisfied
on the right.
So the picture is
not wrong, it's just
not a direct use of the
definition of increasing
returns, and this
was constant returns.
So this is aggregating
production sets.
This one plus this one equals
this one plus the endowments.
So there was a lovely
discussion on Piazza
about this thing, which is,
have we generated a free lunch?
Evidently from the
picture, the answer
is no because there is that
finite production possibilities
frontier over here.
Depending on where
you are, you're
using one as an
input and the other
as an output or vice versa.
The possibility is
created here, however,
that you use x as the input,
getting y as the output.
Take y as the output,
put it in as an input
in the second technology.
Take y as the input,
get x as the output.
So if you kept going like that,
and you got more in output
than you used in input after
going through one cycle,
you could go to infinity.
There'd be no end to it.
It would not only
be a free lunch,
it'd be an infinite lunch.
You could just keep
going, in which case,
although it's not
entirely obvious,
you could never
draw this picture
because there'd be no boundary.
You'd always be in the interior.
You could always do
better just by cloning.
And then we define the firm's
problem, maximizing profits.
We drew these pictures.
Again, you get into the
habit, if you're an economist-
maximize subject to.
Maximize linear function
subject to convex constraints.
You end up with
these tangent cases.
In this case, these
are isoprofit lines
not isobudget lines.
We want to move out as far as
we can on the isoprofit line.
But the tangency
is a similar thing
if we move across these
applications from consumer
theory to producer theory.
So hopefully, it's starting
to become second nature.
We defined properties of
the production function,
including convexity.
And we proved it.
And then almost out of order,
this definition of homogeneity
popped up.
So one thing we didn't do
was link these definitions
of homogeneity of functions
back to the discussion
of increasing, decreasing,
and constant returns to scale.
But you should be
able to do that.
This was a proof of
Hotelling's lemma.
And it was an illustration
of the envelope
theorem, which is
another tool that's
going to keep popping up.
Special versions of
profit maximization,
cost minimization--
so this is like the dual, except
this one's going to get used,
not just to show equivalence.
What I mean by that is this--
so we have this isoproduction
curve called isoquant,
and we're going to try to find
the cost-minimizing bundle that
allows you to achieve that
given level of output.
Then you could do
two experiments.
Just like with the
household, we varied
income and varied prices.
Here, you can vary prices.
And that's the
Walt Disney thing.
So the input mix would change.
What you could also
do, although we
decided not to
overwhelm you, is pick
a different level of output--
a higher level-- and find the
cost-minimizing combination
of inputs to support
that higher output.
And the definition of a
cost curve was defined.
Cost function takes the
input prices as given,
but also the output.
So this is kind of
obvious when you say it.
This is the cost of
producing a given output.
Yes, that's true.
But we never showed the picture.
But we did show the costs.
They're sitting
here in this slide.
Average cost, marginal
costs, and what
happens when you change prices
with constant returns to scale?
If the price were
too high, the outcome
would not be well
defined because they
would make infinite profit.
And then when I presented
this, I said there was a typo,
and there is no typo.
So I apologize twice.
It's fine.
What's going on is the
dialogue in the text below is
moving from here to the
intermediate line to this line.
So when price of the
output is going up,
this thing is going down.
These lines are getting flatter.
And when they get sufficiently
flat, then you go ballistic
and you can make infinite
profits, which is
consistent with this diagram.
Except that it's never
defined at a higher price
because there is no
determinate outcome.
Then this thing
I will set aside,
but again, I asked you to try
to write down a little bit
better proof that these input
ratios are constant when you
have constant returns to scale.
Although this is a version
of in consumer theory,
the idea that with
homothetic utility,
the expenditure shares
don't move, and so on.
So it is related to that.
This was a picture
of Robinson Crusoe.
This was the first general
equilibrium economy
although it was only one
person, with a production
set and preferences.
When I said you should be
able to take that labor supply
and convert it by making
the labor supply negative,
I had this in mind, except
that unlike a production set,
you just have a straight budget
line emanating from the origin,
and then you would
maximize utility.
You're just basically flipping
the diagram from right
to left like an overlay.
But here, there is production.
And this was an exciting
part because we got to trade.
So now we're talking about a
real, live economy with two
goods, agriculture and
output, and looking
at what the consumer would do
if they were maximizing utility
subject to that production
set, as opposed to what
they would do if they were able
to trade in the world economy.
They would produce more
of the manufacturing good,
and export it, and consume
both goods in such a way
that their utility is higher.
So this is-- I can't
remember if I emphasized it,
but this illustrates
the gains to trade.
It's the gains to trade for a
single consumer like Robinson
Crusoe, which you
can see evidently
has higher utility
because they get
to trade away from the origin.
Of course, we
should ask ourselves
whether this is a realistic
description of the economy
or whether we should
populate it with more people,
and potentially have
heterogeneous utility
functions.
And for that, we're going
to need to talk about
whether or not we
can aggregate up,
which comes up in lecture 15
or 16, or something like that.
And this is the US and England
trading with one another.
Questions?
So I'm going to be brief.
Otherwise, we're
going to go over.
This is decision making
under uncertainty, and also
illustrative of linear programs.
So I think on this
one in particular,
I want you to let me know
if you have questions.
It is a bit unnatural.
This part's all very natural.
It just has to do with
a household evaluating
nontrivial lotteries
over prizes, although we
used it to define means
and variances, coefficients
of variation, and
variances, and correlations.
We did all of that.
But then we went back to
the award or the prize
being two-dimensional, in
this case, goods X1 and X2.
So this is a discrete,
non-convex consumption set.
And miraculously, we turned
it into a convex-looking set.
And we had a good
discussion at the beginning
of the following class
about how to do that.
But I want to make sure
you all understand it,
because we're going to build
on it in subsequent lectures.
So one of you asked
me in my office hours,
it's kind of weird--
in finance, you
take as given the returns on
the assets or their beliefs
about the returns.
We don't talk about
choosing the returns.
But here you do, because
you're choosing the lottery.
You're choosing a
random way, although it
could be subject to a budget.
I'm practically out of time.
We went to concave utility.
We talked about behavior
under risk, different types
of utility functions,
this tree that we
keep coming back to that was
at the end of the lecture
last time.
This is Arrow-Debreu security,
so in this case, instead
of having a pure borrowing and
lending economy or borrowing
subject to a credit limit,
we could have had them
trading in an asset which
yields a return of 1
in one state and nothing
in the other states.
And you could be either making
that promise as a borrower,
so to speak, or buying
it as an investor.
So we can go from
medieval villages
to sophisticated securities.
And then we kind of talked about
this at the beginning of class.
And this class ended with
linear programming problems
and how they crop up in
general in utility maximization
and linear activity analysis.
This linear activity analysis
is the Leontief thing
I was alluding to when
we went over preferences.
These are constants.
These A a j is the amount
of good i, input i,
required to produce good
j, and it's a constant.
The rate of substitution
isn't varying
that delivers these
l-shaped isoquants.
All right, so I'm going to have
to stop because otherwise we're
going to go over.
So we almost got to the end.
I don't think I have anything
usually uncovered anyway.
Because the other
two lectures were
the dynamics, which should be
fresh in your mind-- we just
covered it recently--
and the one
that we did and reviewed at
the beginning of the lecture
today on Pareto-optimal
allocations.